breathing's from Podcast village Monday
the 28th the January you bad
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by
Squarespace
are you ready to start a new business
you want it to stand out we'll get
started with Squarespace think it dream
it and make it with Squarespace destiny
is calling it says you need to make our
new website so do me a favor make it
with 12 space the future is coming make
it brighter with Squarespace what I'm
gonna do is this a lot of people don't
even know what Squarespace is you could
create a beautiful website turn your
ideas into a website you can blog or
publish content and you could sell
products the services of all kind
Squarespace does this by giving you
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers what I'm gonna do
is this head to squarespace.com right
now right now and get a free trial when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code Church CH you are CH to save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain that squarespace.com enter
church the church is also brought to you
by on it
listen it's a new year with a new set of
rules you're trying to be a better
person beside your goals on it is the
way to start it whether it's the Alpha
brain or the shrimp Texas water the
shroom tech immune you know I live and
die by these things on is the way to go
do me a favor go to Hana calm right now
a little bit great selection of
supplements that they have from the
other oils to the to the to the to the
jerky I mean everything is top-notch
I know Aubrey I know how his mind works
he is a brilliant man if you really
really want to get your mind in tune and
started alpha brain is the way to go
you got a 100% money-back guarantee even
if you don't take the product who else
does that nobody on it so do me a favor
go down to calm right now press enter CH
BAM and get 10% delivered to your
[ __ ] house alright take this
[ __ ] meal Lee Duncan [ __ ] truffle
on a Monday morning who's better than us
ah thank you for having me man
it's so cool this is so wonderful to
finally be on your show this is
first time we've been at this studio
yeah that's right if I've been on your
show before yeah on the phone but not in
studio alive I don't like one of my
house not in studio no I wanted guys
house the night that you sent us we did
the acids the video that's right
transgender guy yeah with Harry you
couldn't know he well he had a [ __ ] I
don't think it was transgender I don't
know what he was he's a small penis you
started singing dancing I sent that to
everybody I remember it was a great joy
to hear you laughing and knowing that
great sent that to you it was awesome
the only person who got pissed at me to
send it to him was Rogen they have tons
of Christians on there Rogan was like
what the [ __ ] are you doing I'm good man
didn't get congratulations on fatherhood
thank you I mean when I had my child you
were the first and at the hospital with
a camera yeah with the breakfast that's
right we spoke about the future and here
we are six years later in the seats a
traverse unbelievable what do you think
when was the child born I the third just
what do you think it's the best 25 days
of the father yeah what are you thinking
so far uh it's well it's like I have had
more experience with death than birth so
cuz I've I've watched both my parents
died and what's wild about it is it
reminds me this thing I heard opposite
stand back-to-back and so there's all
these similarities in birth and death
that are it's the complete opposite so
in death you've got the hospice worker
who comes and birth you have the Midwife
in death when people are dying they like
something else enters the room like it's
amazing it's beautiful
it's calming it's the opposite of what
you might think it would be it's like it
reminds you of something it's that sense
of like you know when you can almost
remember a song but you can't remember
it but it's like what is this this is
some I've know what this is but it's
surreal you know it's like there's a
thing you get rid of a fait light you
ever heard of a light so when someone's
dying they have a kind of light around
them sometimes I had this guy on who
does who studies
deaf people who come back you like we're
brain dead or their heart stopped and
it's a fascinating phenomenon because
all over the planet they all report the
same [ __ ] thing but I was item what
do they say when they come back so it
goes some it's like you used to light
thing you see a light you see yourself
your body but you look different then
the way you look in a mirror because
you're seeing yourself for the first
time because when you look at yourself
in the mirror just seems a reflection
but in this way you're like you look
different
apparently then you thought you looked
and then I guess like hearing your voice
for the first time on a tape recorder
and then also you the the what's called
the life review happens which is yeah
you sort of we think of it the movies
they usually show it like you're like
watching a TV or something and it's like
you know you're why like Scrooge or some
[ __ ] watching what you did but there's
more of a sense of not just watching it
but feeling the way you made everyone
around you feel and so you feel the way
you made the people around you feel and
there's some justice in there and some
sadness in there and some you know love
and there and joy in there and just feel
how you impacted the world while you
were there
and then then a universally this is
around the planet they report this a
[ __ ] like monkey comes running out of
the darkness and [ __ ] your mouth for
like ten minutes
and then that's usually you wake back up
in your body but the monkey thing they
don't talk about a lot it's really
[ __ ] weird but that's you know I just
remembered all the highlights of my life
that I yearned to see yeah there was a
movie that was released in the 70s
called Beyond and back and I've never
been able to find it it was in the movie
theatres I paid to go see it about
people who had death experiences came
back and reported what they saw yeah I
was involved in something when I was a
kid where I wasn't in the room but I was
tight with the brother and the mom
the whole family she had a brain tumor
that night she went into a coma or
something like that little night she
snapped out of the coma and said open
the window my grandfather wants me to go
she was tight with her grandfather they
were like what are you saying and she's
like just open the window my grandpa
wants me to go on then she ended up
living she doesn't remember I asked her
he is later we had grown up together and
I go what when you went under where did
you go and she goes
it was just warm yeah she was I just
felt warmth so I've always believed you
were saying that wood across the street
from the funeral box that's right I was
like I've always lived close to
something to do with a funeral I've
always had death around me and it's very
sad but it's death and birth are very
similar yeah do feel I've been in the
room for two birds and I've been in one
room when somebody was dead I found him
dead and then I've been to tons of
funerals that's why I don't go to wakes
because of that feeling right but even
at a wait there's a sense of warmth in
the room yeah that's right even at awake
I'm sad and more but it is there is a
sense of warmth yeah beyond warmth I
mean it's a you know what work we're
just figuring things out here yeah as a
species we're just figuring things out
and one of the qualities of being a
human these days is you just sort of
naturally think we figured everything
out you know like it's a thing you just
say oh yeah no no we know now that this
or that but we don't know anything man
we don't know anything I said this crow
researcher on my podcast she discovered
the Crozier necrophiliacs you know crows
[ __ ] the corpses of dead crows they just
found that out they didn't know that 5%
of crows if a crows around a dead body
5% of crows will [ __ ] it and then
another crow will like land on the crow
and [ __ ] the crow they just found that
out that's like new data but I was
asking her other stuff you know she's
studying birds and like there's so much
we just said
no idea about birds do animals fear
death do you think well the crows have
funerals like when it when a crow
encounters a dead crow it calls other
crows into the area so all these other
crows land around the dead crow and they
react to it in a very specific way
elephants when they find bones they like
lift them up and like seem to have some
connection with them so there's like a
few animals besides humans who sort of
react to death with some sense of
realizing that this is sad this is
mournful this is there's something in it
that's poignant and and but you know man
we're like we think so we don't know
death is the great unknown big question
mark we have no [ __ ] idea what it is
which some people think nothing
nothingness absolute oblivion you're
gone forever I don't believe it
well I think it's I don't either but I
think it would be a [ __ ] hilarious if
it is the truth but something that I've
lived through as a 56 year old man tells
me there's something out there
oh yeah there's people who look over us
there's angels there so sure there's
something I just did the Danny Brown
thing and we talked about ghosts and I
know for a fact for a fact that this is
Joey talking to you as a man would the
house I grew up in the North Bergen that
house had ghosts in it disgruntled
ghosts yeah
disgruntled ghosts that I had to move
out of there the two years I went to
school I lived that was my house my
mother that was my family yeah but I
stayed at her friend's house the whole
sixth grade year and a half the seventh
year I stayed at my house I stayed away
from the house and then after my mother
died was when I found out that a guy had
killed himself in the garage he did the
hole closed a garage and you know carbon
monoxide outside and then when we were
kids we would walk around and there was
woods on our block there was a big brick
wall yeah and they told us that it was
an orphanage
we were growing up it was and then
somebody about seven years ago put some
up on Facebook
the real story about to given that
orphanage and it was on giving that
Terrace in Charles Court and there was
an orphanage that burnt down and a bunch
of kids died in there
yeah so they just took that those two
blocks one there's a loop block one of
those blocks that you loop around yeah
and give her that Terrace is a dead end
so they always said there was a tattoo
book book bad luck bad luck blocks yeah
so I lived there I my mother died the
kid two doors door died from me died
when we were growing up just something
the energy even when I go down there now
the house is the sale oh the house is
for sale you're ready the house yeah why
gross I just I still got it on my phone
the picture houses for sale at once 350
I thought about it for about two minutes
I don't have to sing 200 into it to
modernize right thousand nineteen I
thought about it but then I thought
about what lived in that house what was
really really really in that yeah I put
a compassionate and you I heard this
[ __ ] on art Bell the best explanation
for ghosts ever which was it's actually
not ghosts it's a time is happening at
once and so like in a place where some
shitty thing happens because like we
perceive time as like being in the
moment we're in right now but that
suicide is like on repeat it's happening
over and over and over and over and
that's what a ghost is a ghost is just
like a kind of echo a temporal echo
that's sort of like trapped in this
dimension and is bouncing right in there
it's like not so much an entity though
on the other hand man I've talked to
many people who say well yeah maybe but
there's [ __ ] like a whole ecosystem
so to speak of sentient disembodied
beings that are around us at all times
and you say that you sound crazy
you know but it wasn't that long ago
that people didn't know there are germs
they didn't know there's bacteria you
know they had no idea they didn't know
you should wash your hand
didn't know there was an if you started
saying oh you know there's like tiny
little evil beings that are actively
trying to kill you that if you just wash
your hands there you have a you're not
gonna get sick as much people look at
you like you're out of your [ __ ] mind
what are you talking about there was a
there's a doctor who started
recommending that other doctors wash
their hands before surgery you know when
they're delivering babies cuz the infant
mortality rate was so high and he'd
figured out like oh yeah if your hands
are dirty
are you [ __ ] blaming me look it up it
there used to be a saying a gentleman
does not wash his hands you know I'm
saying what you just changed what year
did this finally I don't know the yeah I
don't know about you I've been washing
my hands since nineteen [ __ ] it I feel
dirt on my hands it drives me crazy I
think it was Lee that's saying yeah he
doesn't like to Joey his hands I don't
like anything sticky yes 18:47 they
first practiced [ __ ] serious yeah man
I got just just new I don't like my
hands dirty
no dude doctors were like would have
their [ __ ] hand in a dead body just
like what the [ __ ] is this they didn't
know what it was yeah it was like to get
just to get the right to look into a
dead body at the time it's not like it
is now yeah and then like they would go
deliver a baby with like [ __ ] nasty
corpse blood all over him and just jerk
they don't just pull the baby out in the
[ __ ] mother would get like you know
the very least vaginosis or something
and the baby would get sick this doctor
ended up in a mental asylum he went
crazy because he knew he was right and
other doctors are like what are you
talking about we don't need to wash our
hands and like he went nuts cuz he knew
he was right is there still a lot to be
discovered and if everything feels so
advanced now Michael there's not much
left daddy to Scott but is there
anything well this is the great that
yeah that you know everyone's talking
about conspiracies all the time this
conspiracy in that conspiracy but the
real conspiracy is the one against
yourself or you trick yourself into
thinking we've figured it all out and
it's insanity
we haven't figured out [ __ ] man I could
have like a huge part of the planets
covered in water we don't know what's
down there
you think we know what's down there we
don't know what's down there
and then there's huge swaths of the
planet that are covered in trees you
know and only just now are kind of
figuring out not to mention the [ __ ]
ice when that stuff's melting now we're
seeing like formations and structures
finding mammoths and [ __ ] in there but
you know it's convenient to imagine that
because you saw like five episodes of
cosmos you now understand everything
about the planet not to mention like
just the obvious [ __ ] right in front of
us which is that dolphins have a
language that we don't know but they're
talking to each other crows talk to each
other they talk to each other you know
they're clear saying [ __ ] and sorry it
sounds like I don't know what that is
mean what we're like trying to listen
aliens we've got massive satellites
China just like invested all this money
and these insane [ __ ] satellites to
try to pick up some alien transmission
you think animals you think cats talk to
each other
I sure wait oh I think they work more
telepathically cats yeah look at my I
had one situation where I broke up two
brothers both of them are dead now but
when we moved we made a mistake and
broke up the brothers Terry took one
brother in one car and I took the
brother in my car and I beat traffic
before her and I brought him into the
apartment first I'll never forget this
and I let the three cats I had loose and
Harry was looking for his brother and he
started making a distinct noise I never
heard again like he just started going
into an anxiety and he was making this
yeah and it wasn't a hiss and nothing it
was just this really weird thing and
when Terry brought deme up and let them
hear they both went up to each other and
started making that noise I never heard
them do it again here and I knew that
that's what I learned the bond between
them I knew that if something would
happen so the other one the other one
can handle and sure enough one one died
and the other one that's crazy I'm not a
very religious person but I don't older
I get its unmistakable how like how
energy is real and like how there is a
connection
between things like is it possible to
believe and all like this stuff like you
were talking about like ghosts and and
energies but like maybe not be like
religious and believe in God are they
separate things are they the same thing
yeah I don't like yeah like I think you
can definitely like you know if you ever
heard a Robert Anton Wilson no he's
great great writer really interesting
dude you know that is Robert he's a
[ __ ] brilliant philosopher and you
know he like has a lot of great books
one of them is called cosmic trigger but
he talks about like the Illuminati right
and he says what he'll explain the
Illuminati to me from scratch from
scratch
I don't sure what happenes people are
talking yeah talks about it yeah well I
mean there's a snow bother it's it's
there's a light merely a luminous I'll
try I mean from what I've read you know
there there's like a historic Illuminati
it I think started in Bavaria you know
which was basically you know we have
freemasons masonry and the Illuminati it
was some kind of society that's I can't
remember the guys name that was
connected to the Masons and so that's
like the you can Wikipedia the
Illuminati it pops up it's not like a
thing someone made up it was just like a
there's I guess the best way to put it
is there's a saying as above so below
right so if you want to understand or in
small things all things so to understand
the Illuminati you could probably think
about like the university system the way
that works which is like if you want to
go to a university you've got to have
good grades in school and not just that
if you have to demonstrate certain
qualities like if you want to go to like
the Ivy League schools and then if you
do that you you you sort of get admitted
into the university and then you get
like high level data given to you that
other people maybe have access to but
they don't get taught it in the way that
it's taught at those schools by just
like you know people who are just super
geniuses you know and some of the great
ripples in society happened because of
the things going on
universities you know the [ __ ]
Unabomber for example Kaczynski man look
that [ __ ] up if you want to trip out
that guy was like getting MKULTRA by
this professor it was at Harvard he was
getting paid to do these weird tests to
figure out if he could break down
somebody's identity you know because
they wanted to the ideal thing would be
like if you can capture somebody an
enemy soldier and not just [ __ ]
interrogate him but wipe his mind
temporarily and put things inside of him
so that when you sent him back he would
do crazy [ __ ] like a time bomb or
something who knows what but they were
really interested in the identity people
think when they hear this they think no
that never happened it's all documented
you can look it up Freedom of
Information Act just look it up it's all
right there online MKULTRA [ __ ]
documents about the many attempts they
made and some of the weirdest [ __ ] you
ever heard
[ __ ] Kaczynski was being like
unethically experimented on by this
professor I can't recall his name
Kaczynski got into Harvard when he was
16 you know he got into [ __ ] Harvard
on a mathematic scholarship at the age
of 16 fell under the spell of this like
crazy-ass mad scientist professor who
was doing [ __ ] to him that I don't think
we'll ever know you know putting him in
rooms and complete darkness for long
periods of time getting him to tell all
the secrets and then humiliating him and
stuff like that so Kaczynski Scientology
well I mean sorry oh like what do you
mean
Scientology takes your secrets alright
they debrief you it's called it yeah
through that system they take your deep
the secrets and then they hold them
against you yeah that will that you know
a confessional professional yes all of
it is the concept is pretty good though
it's like secrets are when you feel
ashamed it's a lot of cognitive weight
to carry around if you have secrets it
feels bad like you don't you know
there's a sense of like it sucks it's
not a great feeling it's it's a lot of
its weight you know you're carrying
weight when you when you have a lot of
Secrets you know so there's some there's
good sides to and bad sides clearly in
this case bad sides you're not supposed
to humiliate someone when they tell you
they're great secrets you're supposed to
give them that's the idea but Gusinsky
you know and we all know what happened
with him but yeah so universities they
take people and train them up in this
way or that those people go out in the
world and they become presidents they
become scientists you know and they do
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] hopefully for
the better that's the that's the idea
for the betterment of society they've
got they gathered all this like you know
specific data you know about some small
branch of like oncology or something you
know they've gotten this deep focused
very expensive education and then they
go and hopefully cure cancer right
that's the idea of universe so with the
Illuminati you could it's kind of like
you could you could ask yourself what do
you think happened first the university
system Ivy League university system you
think that just appeared suddenly
schooling people giving people secret
information like giving people like the
big downloads no it's been around
forever you know which is why there was
you know Mason's the secrets of the
Carpenters and people who just build
[ __ ] there were no books you would like
become an apprentice someone well
there's a Mason doesn't those are the
people I yelled that day you yelled at
the Free Masons there's a church I don't
know what a YMCA is I just beat them all
outside with torches and I beat them and
call them [ __ ] December the way
they're not I think makes them they're
like a group isn't it like Richard Pryor
was amazing really yeah so what is
amazing exactly I mean you know I don't
really know
they're pretty secretive aren't they
well they say we're not a secret society
we're a society with secrets but they
they're just a fraternal Brotherhood of
people who have been stigmatized in a
pretty intense way but just because they
have secrets because they like or
apparently engaged in some kind of
disciplined practice that is helping
them understand what it means to be like
a contributing member to society
basically like their whole thing is like
helping your community I'll commute
always well my dad was a Mason you know
my grandfather was a male in the South
many people in Mason's I mean the name
Mason you hear it all the [ __ ] time
but stonemasons you know the the people
build all the cathedrals and the
churches and stuff that you know we take
it all for granted right like the
[ __ ] arches that hold up cathedrals
we see that [ __ ] oh my god that's pretty
that's beautiful
but we don't realize like how
significant in the history of
architecture it was when people figured
out how to do that how to like
distribute weight in that way you know
it's [ __ ] amazing right and that used
to be a secret how to do that that was a
secret and and so then the reason for
that being a secret I think was probably
based on a few different things one
would be I don't want to give you this
information if you're not good enough to
build one of these [ __ ] things
because if I give you this information
you go and try to build it you could
kill people and that's gonna be on my
back that I gave you this information
and you were like lazy or weak or
whatever and then you [ __ ] up and now
everything falls apart
alright so I would imagine if there was
some repository of information out there
that was like gave people extra
abilities or something like if there was
like information maybe about what
happens after you died or where we are
actually in the universe or what
dimension this is and why we're here and
what's going on or in and there was some
sense that if you told someone that they
would either misunderstand it completely
and then like going Yap about it to
everybody and cause all kinds of
problems or more often than not they
might go nuts you know they might not be
able to handle it
the Masons just meant it's just a men's
group it's a fraternal organization yeah
which means just met just men okay yeah
and then so wait just just a circle back
a little bit to the Illuminati what are
they doing
do they really control everything or is
it just like a group of smarter people I
don't know I mean I don't have no my
feeling with it is like you know if you
look throughout history at the people
who make a ripple in history for the
better
Martin Luther King Gandhi John Lennon
what are they all have in common
they all got assassinated they all got
[ __ ] shot so oh jesus let's so Jesus
in there right so my feeling would be
like Tupac anybody who is making big
ripples and telling the truth in a
really beautiful way inevitably gets
offed right and so what you're seeing
there is a brilliant person who has
contacted truth with a good heart who
wants the world to be better and
actively pursues that goal successfully
to the point where they rise into the
mainstream and things do begin to change
a little bit because of them and then
look what happens some [ __ ] [ __ ]
shoots them and so my guess would be
that if there is like a continuum of
intelligence and if you don't think
there's a continuum of intelligence
you're fooling yourself man some people
are really smart I've been around them
and some people are you know very
distracted you know to put it nicely and
so I would imagine that the very smart
people scanning the world and looking at
what happens when you overtly try to
change the world they're like I don't
wanna get [ __ ] shot
I love the world but is it so effective
to enter the world and start telling the
truth if nine times out of ten you get
blasted before you finish the job so you
know do they control everything I don't
know but I would guess that because in
nature camouflage the ability to
camouflage is such an important trait
right when it comes to evolution you
know when it comes to surviving that I
would imagine that there were probably
some highly intelligent people who were
more than likely connected via some kind
of I don't know what some system no
conspiracy theory here do you think like
Joplin Hendricks and Jim Morrison's
that's or connectors anyway if you had a
make a hypothesis like the [ __ ] if
you read documents that
days leading up doing something yeah man
I don't know why everyone I don't even
know why that's [ __ ] surprising to
people look at Caesar look what happened
to him stabbed to death you know looked
like a powerful people are often
murdered throughout history I don't know
why suddenly people think that it's like
beyond the pale that folks who had a any
kind of charisma that seemed to be
working against whatever the particular
system was or whoever was in power at
the time and looking [ __ ] Nixon you
know I don't know if Nixon was president
when they died by the way I'm not sure
exactly but look at the what he created
what he the the sorrow that [ __ ]
[ __ ] harvested in his sick
prohibition of psychedelics not because
he thought psychedelics were bad because
he didn't like hippies and he didn't
like black people and he wanted to
figure out a way to arrest him you know
you wanted to figure out a way to get
into these like growing communities and
like arrest them and you can't arrest
people for ideas so you need some
[ __ ] reason to do it so it's like Oh
what do they all have in common they're
smoking weed they're getting high they
they're there and also not only that but
they're smoking weed and they're getting
high and they're getting information
from it and even worse their the
information they're getting they're
turning it into art and the artists
changing society in a way that doesn't
work if you're trying to run a [ __ ]
military-industrial complex right and so
if you're running a military-industrial
complex your job is killing people so it
doesn't seem beyond the pale that if you
are a threat to a like massive global
organization that makes money from
exploding people they would [ __ ] kill
you if they found you to be a threat it
doesn't seem that weird it's like now is
that what happened I don't know but I
wouldn't like if I heard it I wouldn't
be like are you kidding me that's crazy
well I kind of makes sense did it happen
I don't know but Robert Anton Wilson to
get back to your question he recommends
agnosticism which is let yourself think
these things if you want use your mind
to like contemplate and think about it
but don't believe it all the way because
once you do that that's a
slippery slope man and that leads to
like a lot of embarrassment
you know just ponder it we're allowed to
speculate and look at the world and look
at patterns for fun - this is fun I
don't know were they assassinated maybe
I could see why if I was running a
military and massive organization and
suddenly some like charismatic hippie
was flopping around making beautiful
[ __ ] music that was making people not
want to go to work anymore and making
war seem bad you know I don't know if I
was evil I might do a code tarantula
whatever I do have all this [ __ ] yeah
that's what I want to know I don't know
I love thinking about it it's fun grab
another one of those thanks man it's a
joy to think about you know look before
you we start the podcast you were
talking about India now these Indians
and you know one thing I've always you
know Rogen's not as spiritual as well I
don't think I think Ari you and I are
very spiritual yeah aware of our
surroundings when I had Bobby Lee in
here we spoke about it did you what did
you feel at the store all those years
not to harp on the comedy store guys I
just wanted you to hear from the talent
chord we were talking about energies and
entities before and break down the
energies and the ghosts yeah you felt at
the store and your ghost sighting if you
have sure man yeah sure yeah so it's
like a thick energy you know it's like
you know how you can like for people
like it seems crazy when you start
talking about this [ __ ] like
clairvoyance or like you know what they
used to call it being sensitive you know
in the sense of like you know they
wouldn't call it even psychic they'll
call it sensitive so the way to
understand it if you've never like felt
a haunted place though I think most
people have is uh just think of the
difference between hot and cold or think
like when you walk into like a super hot
place like when you walk into a spa that
feeling you hit a wall
he it's like a very specific feeling
it's a dense energy in there so like the
next time you're in a very hot place
like that feel it that energy the [ __ ]
the way that it feels weird it's a
different feeling in there the air feels
different it is different I'm sure cuz
if they eat so similarly if you use that
exact same sense when you go into
certain places every once in a while
it's like you walked into a fog but
there's nothing there but you can feel
it it's dense the Energy's thick coiled
up it's thick so the comedy soars like
that it's the energy is it's very it's a
certain places have tendencies that's a
good way to put it you know just like
certain people have tendencies certain
places I have tendencies you know
repeating patterns so that one of the
tendencies of a Comedy Store is it tends
to create really great [ __ ] comics
that's one of its tendencies you know it
gives birth spits out these comedians
every once in a while that like become
very successful and it has other
tendencies too right and we know about
the other tendencies that it adds to so
the energy there is very powerful and
real and if you are Very's if you're
even still if you don't the worst thing
is to not know you're sensitive to just
think you're normal oh man
you are [ __ ] if you go to that place
because it'll start [ __ ] with you a
little bit and which is why all these
like people you have a variety of mental
illnesses would show up there throughout
the years you know it almost would draw
them to it but I'll tell you man a ghost
experience to ghost experiences that I
had there one we would have clairvoyance
come in there every once in a while like
once a year clairvoyant would come in
and want to like try to communicate with
the spirit of the place because it's a
legendary haunted place and so this
clairvoyant comes and they're like do
you can we just walk through the
building I just want to see if I can
communicate with the spirits here and so
we're walking through the building and
they're you know they're doing the usual
clairvoyance [ __ ] which I'm pretty
skeptical about you know because it's
like if you name a certain number of
names
you're gonna hit something so the name
stuff that they do I don't know I don't
usually pay attention to you know like
I'm sensing a william brothers brothers
some kind of brothers there was a thin
no no no
and also it's a researchable building so
it's like anything you say is not going
to make me feel like it's proof of
something if you're in a historic
building but you know that's the steps
going up to the belly room yes and
there's like a sign at the bottom of the
steps there
I think it's neon it definitely has
lights I don't know what inside the
outside so out inside the right you make
the right turn you go to our steps and
there's that there's our there's a neon
sign right okay so they go by that she
goes by that sign and stops and starts
me oh there's a it's a it's that's what
she say it's brothers who says some kind
of so someone there's something happy
she's like doing is straight out of
poltergeist [ __ ] and that was pretty
weird but you know pretty good act and
then that [ __ ] sign man it starts
going it's reacting I never seen that
sign do that
that I saw with my own [ __ ] eyes now
what that was I have no idea but it
creeped me out the other thing I saw
there was really interesting and I think
you know when people talk about the
ghost of The Comedy Store they figure
like Casper something with a sheet over
its head or some kind of like you know
stereotypical ghost concept but if you
think about it more in terms of like an
energetic there's an energetic form
there that repeats itself this will make
more sense and that's what the ghost is
but I was like state I was looking down
the hallway at the belly room and I was
just watching some comics and some dumb
fight you know just fighting you
[ __ ] they were like you know I
don't know I don't know the comics were
they were like someone in a belly room
show but they're on a pretty intense
fight and I was just watching it I
couldn't hear him they left right and
then within like three minutes in that
very same spot two different people got
in the same [ __ ] fight same movement
saying like that
I'm sitting there watching like an echo
of the same [ __ ] thing I just saw
with two different people now assuming
that this wasn't some conspiracy where
some weird goddamn freakish improv on
the spot people are trying to [ __ ] with
some solitary belly room comedian
sitting on the couch then that indicates
to me that there was like a kind of Eddy
like a ripple that was happening there
like a little [ __ ] an energetic
ripple that people who weren't protected
or who weren't who are a little too
reactive when they were getting in it
they were acting like it
oh and then you know trying to make
sense of it later that's the thing so
many people just do [ __ ] and then they
try to make sense of it later you know
like I don't even know why they did it
they just do a thing and then later they
try to make sense of it you know that
happens all over the planet like you if
you've been watching this Ted Bundy
documentary or not yet not yet a couple
people hit me up on it yeah yeah
so quote Walter let's have one story
where I saw whatever I saw at this door
was at the top of the belly room I was
Mitty was in a chair in the main room
and I didn't want to walk past her so I
stood by the door watching whoever was
on stage and I felt an energy over my
right shoulder and I kept focusing in
the comic but something was hitting my
eyes something was making that light not
blink
but like somebody was standing in front
of it and when I finally did decide to
look up it was like the person it was
like Kennison it looked like the
Tennyson type took his jacket spun it
like a cape and walked into the belly
room yeah like oh [ __ ]
yeah whatever I felt Jay and I can feel
his cold air whatever that was it that
was my only ghostly experience at the
thing back to Bundy this is the really
weird thing with me when I moved to
Snowmass Village in 83 I moved up there
July 1st of 83 you know I adapted to the
area within too much
and one day I had a friend that was a
chef that's certain so I Brees hired him
how he made his living in the winter was
people would come in and they would hire
him as a chef Michael Douglas Sydney
pornog people like that sure and he had
Jack Nicholas says the guy's name is
brandy and one night who had just walked
into a bar that was called it was like
the local watering hole on Friday nights
in Snowmass Village and he showed me he
showed me the hotel where Bundy first
took a woman last village up and uh see
if you defined it Bundy in Snowmass
Village I think I just saw it on the
doctor I never forget the name of the
[ __ ] a hotel this is the reporter is
this the reporter he was like she was on
the news I do not I don't remember all
the fact and then when he escaped from
Hoffman County Jail I mean [ __ ] no
offense Lee Lee is not a criminal and
Lee could escape from Aspen County jab
okay okay Lee's not a completely just
walk out the door and trap the Wolves do
this in the wild went in with the wild
wood and there you go that's when he
took the chicks from me brought down for
me so now I'm up and asked him one day
at day in and out the internet was a
restaurant that my buddy Steve Schiavoni
who still comes to my shows when I
perform a buffalo or Florida cuz he's
retired now it was he was a cook at the
time at this playable wasn't even cook
it was a Sam what was the place called
the in and out it's not like in-and-out
burger it's all restaurants is 1993
gotcha half the size of this place
catch it three people could stand there
I can't time the order of Sandwich
everybody else understand that's right
and we were talking when they were
smuggling joining front of the place
yeah he showed me the window a Bundy
escape from and crazy a path he took so
now I go back to New York and get my
problems I know I started comedy and I
moved to Seattle and then Seattle Bundy
I had done some damage he did some real
death yeah yeah yeah
and when dam up and see how somebody
goes through the a
like somebody who lived in the area goes
bundy lived like three blocks in here
for like a month with a girl well no
it's like when I went to your house one
time you
you showed me where the tape LaBianca
Bernie yeah when there wasn't was it
close no that's up in um Silver Lake
Jesus Christ I read it's not the taalib
yunk i don't think it's the other ones
it's like there's it's not the it's one
of the murders I don't remember what
tomorrow yeah yeah Jesus Christ oh I
read that book I didn't think it was his
neighborhood helter skelter Skeletor
many scary [ __ ] done some scary [ __ ] you
know about creepy crawly
No so that's what I that's what it's
like some of our neighbors at the time
they've been there fro they were right I
read that you were telling me when I
went there was I gonna do a podcast you
were living with a different girl then
this is seven years ago yeah well the
neighbors said that all of a sudden they
just like wouldn't notice he's like
[ __ ] dirty hippies wandering around up
there you know and it was the Manson
Family
they were like scoping it out and they
noticed it you know they were like oh
you know it's not like they're gonna
they're gonna blend in in that area he's
our [ __ ] it's the family man he's got
they've been drinking acid you know
they've been drinking LSD up at spawn
ranch saying [ __ ] like Manson could like
levitate school buses and like Gerry
hear that story no oh yeah that's one of
the stories they said is like they like
I think it's their school bus they were
in got stuck in front of some rocks and
Manson levitated it and flew it over the
rocks and [ __ ] like they were high was
Manson levitating school buses or where
they just hire an acid I mean Occam's
razor tells us [ __ ] acid but you know
that thing where they were like that guy
wanted to kill himself all that was
[ __ ] or something he was [ __ ] one of
the Manson girls and like he like she
shot him in the face and he came inside
of her well he died or something I mean
these were like hardcore hardcore
cultists like the Manson Family was like
it makes any other [ __ ] cult
how many people were the Manson Family
I'm not sure it's a great question
I could start right here in [ __ ]
California dude it's weird [ __ ]
Manson was like teetering on the brink
of being a musician he's hanging out
with the Beach Boys one of the Beach
Boys stole his [ __ ] song you know
that song it's called like something his
music is pretty good too that's the
other thing Mantha's music is not bad
it's not like you could see how like
with just like if he had just made a
left turn instead of a right turn and
just met the right person we'd be
talking about him the way we talk about
[ __ ] yeah yeah sure dude he was
hangout the Beach Boys that was one of
the theories about the the house
rosemarys but was the beyond No
so he killed the director of Rosemary's
baby's wife pregnant wife wife yeah
right Peter Buck who's the director not
Peter I'm so sad I can't remember it's
one of my favorite movies right
Rosemary's Baby yeah yeah but the theory
is and forgive me for the Manson like
trivia people out there if I'm [ __ ]
butchering this but essentially the
theory is they ripped him off man they
took one of his songs and they did can
you google that do you mind googling
listen oh I was just looking there's 12
of them so what do you want me to google
google beach boys stole Manson song
though [ __ ]
yeah I mean I wanna show them over the
top well he that's that house he went at
to he thought the producer he thought
some producer was there was a vengeance
killing or something apparently it was
an accident to go to the house that's
one of the theories you know but
regardless these were some [ __ ] did
you find it yeah it's the never look all
done because I just went up to it yeah
his song ceased to exist
turned into never one not to love yeah
dude
they used tilling with the [ __ ] Peter
I heard that so what you said well this
is what I heard [ __ ] you invite
Manson to your party and he comes with a
swarm of these beautiful crazy hippie
girls right so he was always he was a
cult leader he's already a cult leader
Sarah and he was so charismatic so he
had this like nice orbit of these
beautiful Manson girls around
like so he was getting you know he was
kind of like rubbing shoulders with
folks and like he was in it for a second
you know and then I'm yeah so new up in
this neighborhood like all of a sudden
like they noticed he's like weird
hippies doing like cartwheels naked and
[ __ ]
they weren't just up there like you know
they weren't even trying they weren't
even pretending to not be seen they were
doing like weird [ __ ] up there like
hippy dances you know making out in the
grass some of them were naked but they
were doing something called creepy
crawly supposedly which is like they
would like break into people's houses
and just go through their [ __ ] for fun
look at this man look at this picture of
this kid man crazy like that and so yeah
and then they you know the murder
started right but it's a really
interesting story when you realize that
Manson actually had a brush with the
potential for fame similarly the same
thing happened with [ __ ] Bundy man he
was a politician he was like getting
into politics a little bit you know like
you see this like rub the law school he
went to law school or something yeah
yeah he was a lawyer something somewhere
it's that like out now see where the
Manson Family started was in California
I think it was California right Southern
California and then he recruited a bunch
of how big were they I'm curious how
many people he had this [ __ ] twelve
eleven and then him so he had 12 people
like the Apostles song like wow Jesus
had 12 apostles that's nuts yeah
California in the late 60s I imagine it
was more than 12
I imagine like you know it's not like
people are like they're killing people
up there Manson's crazy was more like
they're these crazy hippies with amazing
acid up its Spahn Ranch you throw
incredible parties we should go hang out
sure there was like a lot really loops
flowing right that's where they were yes
bond rulers all right I'm not sure and
then find out who was the director cuz I
remember that she her name was Nancy
Roman Polanski then he got in trouble
for molesting a 16 year old girl
that's right years later and he's not
allowed back into the country I knew
there was just a lot they took a baby
how it was
still alive and they killed it you want
to hear the conspiracy theory about
Rosemary's Baby yeah right yeah be movie
you know the conspiracy theory about it
you wanna hear a really creepy
conspiracy again when I say this I don't
believe it necessarily it's just like I
like conspiracy theories in the way I
like mythology's you know it's
interesting you know but one of the
conspiracy theories about it is because
they you know we're shooting this sort
of like they got a little bit you know
these days you see these possession
movies you know they're embarrassing
like the possession of Britney Lindsay
or whatever the [ __ ] white like seven
possession movies out there the
possession of a band of French and it's
just like there's this depiction of
Satanism in it or debt the devil or
spirits and it's just like you watch
like that's such [ __ ] and that's not
what it's like
so Rosemary's Baby supposedly was a
little too they hit the nail on the head
so to speak
they showed a little too much about like
how some of the [ __ ] goes down and
because of that a message had to get
sent which is like guys if you come to
our party don't put it on the screen man
that's for your eyes only
what are you doing were you doing
research when you came to our black mass
that was for your eyes only you know now
you're gonna [ __ ] turn it into a
movie no no that happened they kill you
no because it's like it's so [ __ ] up
so [ __ ] up I mean I don't think it's
true well no any level of it's [ __ ] up
now if his eyes wide shut true like I
heard any a bunch of people talking 1-9
about eyes wide shut the movie with the
Scientologists great movie I really love
the whole eyes wide shut
how much is it true yeah he goes they
have Hollywood parties like that ya know
and it's a bunch of rich white guys with
masks on you know your [ __ ] have you
got a little stainless well yeah well
there's like what's it called there's
like some Fight Club you could join in
Hollywood called nexium or something it
didn't kick quickly tell us about that
it's like a it's like a swinger thing
yeah it's like swingers dude the reality
of it is man like it's long talking
about mother
does that [ __ ] you and they kill you
okay in pieces by San Diego up so the
classic theory is this and I do not
believe this but the classic theory is
this and you can read about it in Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas that fantastic
scene where a hunter has Thompson talks
about having some like drug that was
extracted from the adrenal gland do you
remember that that chapter right yes and
he says he got I think in the day when
you write devices he got it from like
some like coltan source a business or
some [ __ ] but that's called it it's
called adrenochrome is the name of it
supposedly if you like take the
adrenaline so if you take this [ __ ] out
of someone who got murdered you get high
as a kite and maybe there's some other
[ __ ] that it does to you right this is
all just conspiracy theory alright so
somebody gets shot in the street they
take them to the hospital what do you do
you take this blood no you take this
like gland or something I'm not really
sure I mean when I was watching this
wonderful [ __ ] awesome documentary on
NASA's connection to like the weird
connection with like NASA and like the
SS and the Nazis and how the Nazis were
all like super into the [ __ ] a cult
man like they were like there's a thing
called the Thule Society and stuff and
like they were like really doing some
crazy [ __ ] over there besides like the
horrific stuff they were doing there's
other stuff they were doing just really
weird [ __ ] and like you know what
happened is we won the war became a
superpower because we got all their
scientists you know the scientists the
Jewish scientists fled but many other
scientists too and also a lot of those
Nazis like you know I can't remember
which company it is like bear some [ __ ]
or like one of the aspirin companies
used to like make psycho again this is
I'm butchering it I don't know if this
is true so forgive me bear will you look
it up to like Bayer and Nazism or Bayer
and likes Bayer Aspirin and like cyclone
V like a lot of these companies were
it's not like this is the this is the
scary [ __ ] man so the war ends thank God
Germany has been crushed thank God it's
over they're blowing up swastikas they
won right and they have the the [ __ ]
trials will they hung a lot of those
[ __ ] right they hung him they
killed him but they didn't kill all them
so where'd they go where'd they go
are those Nazis where'd they go man for
you that's what they say right so many
of them like kind of went out into the
world also what happened all the money
they stole where did that go
was it all brought back did we get all
the money back from those [ __ ]
occultist Psychopaths where did the
money go
right so this is one of the creepy
things and you know conspiracy theory
circles is just like what happened to
all the Nazis did we get them all
there's a thing called the Thule Society
you know uh which was like some kind of
channeling group that was getting
information from entities about how to
build ships and crafts and stuff and
like crazy [ __ ] now this is where the
problem is all this stuff is like all
that I'm saying I've harvested what I'm
really high off of incredibly ridiculous
websites you know what I mean so and
also I'm so my articulation of it's
probably not even accurate at all I get
a little bummed out actually when I see
people doing the sort of like satanic
panic thing to people who practice magic
you know because I think it's like
really [ __ ] up you know like it's
bigoted I think and so what ends up
happening is you see these like
depictions of something very real which
is that there ain't just [ __ ] Judaism
and Christianity and Islam and Buddhism
in the world man there's a lot of other
religions too and a lot of other ways of
connecting with the universe but when
people engage in those practices then
they get painted in this really dark way
as being evil minions of the devil it's
like you know cursed or something like
that
I I find that to be like a real
mischaracterization of something you
never consider joining a cult I mean
since you've been out here in California
have you beat people have been in cults
or anything cuz I don't think California
then there's a state that allows I think
it's Indiana or one of those I've just
told her the podcast before I dated a
girl who grew up in a cult and I till
this day don't understand cults
yeah they just released something about
Jim Jones they just realized somewhere
cuz I just so I think it's Netflix or
something but I just never understood
the whole cult thing I was intimate with
somebody for four years who grew up in a
cult and their stories for horrific I
talked their twenty times into arresting
her parents like I would tell her you
should have it's a sad phenomena man
it's like sad people the problem is
people don't know what they are you know
yes they do yes they do
some people don't you cannot look at me
we live in San Francisco I go to
Duncan's Church I'm through with
Catholicism I tried being a Lutheran it
didn't work for me but this guy Duncan
Trussell it's it's a religion based on
this and his whatever when I kind of dig
it yeah and I go there on Sunday so I
could feel good about myself yeah I just
want to feel good about myself
sure I don't want to be trapped in the
Catholic Church I want to be involved in
my community yeah so I walked into
Duncan's church and I like what he says
and we kind of goes there with his wife
and they dig it it's real low-key and
it's yeah it's Christianity light shadow
and next thing you know I'm giving you
ten percent and the next thing you know
you come to me you say you want to move
to [ __ ] in an island the whole cult yeah
and we pick up and go to joint Jonestown
Guyana yeah you know like that's where I
think the buck ends for me like that's
where but he started having problems up
in San Francisco already like well he
went to Guyana you
he was all it was already starting to
come out and he had he was a horrible he
had a horrible drug addiction he was
addicted to speed shooting intravenously
yeah man well do they consider
themselves Colts like coach sounds
almost like a [ __ ] like obviously there
couldn't so most of them are crazy I
couldn't find out anything you need to
think about half the people you've met
the last 20 years in Lausanne yeah I say
5% of the people we've met they could
fall until they follow some behind time
Scientology has no really religious base
to it it's about it's based on a book by
l ron Hubbard and you go in there and
they put you next year are you spending
$80,000 a year
then what that's a cult what's the
difference between Catholicism in a cult
you go home left a mess yeah you go home
after Scientology I imagine you go home
after many what some people did you get
involved with it you're in there and
then I think once you move in then you
go into normal houses but just I've
watched with Lea says and I've watched a
couple all that I watch the documentary
on and I watch it Lea sometimes I watch
that show just because my questions
while I'm watching this [ __ ] show is
that how stupid are you like I don't
know I'm sorry to be judgmental but
while I'm watching all these stories
yeah I'm sitting there going how stupid
are you
yeah like the guy had a [ __ ] anaconda
he took all your money he was selling
parrots he was like saying crazy [ __ ]
when you which one are you talking about
Jim Jones or any of them like right
through up without like a girl I was
involved with the more we dated the more
we got high and drank she would break
down and tell me little things right now
again if we comes to me tomorrow and it
was a man I loved my experience with you
here I think you're wrong I'm gonna
become a Scientologist I wish him luck
sure and whatever there's nothing
there's nothing I could do yeah well
yeah came to me and said I'm quitting
tomorrow me my wife and the two kids
moving on to the compound
have a problem with me because the kids
are innocent victims this is your belief
and Johnny don't leave your wife and
your kids to come home and do whatever
the [ __ ] you want but don't involve them
in it can I play the role of a cult
leader for a second argue with you guys
so the so it's like here we we're doing
this thing called society all right I'm
already Scott kind of talking like
Manson we're doing this thing it's
called society you know and let's just
look at society the normal pattern that
people engage in right now think about
it
we live in a time period where it's so
expensive to buy a house that both
parents have to work right mostly so
many people right now both parents have
to work so we are living in a time where
the parents are not being shipped off to
a cult compound but they are being
shipped off so to speak in their cars to
separate office buildings where they
have to work eight hours a day whether
kids are putting a [ __ ] daycare
center that they could barely afford and
I've heard about some of these daycare
centers and people working there now sad
it is the kids just lay on the floor
crying there's not enough people they
can't afford to take care of sitter
where your kid gets actually human to
human contact so you got these [ __ ]
daycare centers all over the country
filled with kids crying for their
parents completely confused what the
[ __ ] is happening their parents they're
fighting they're stressed out they want
to be with a baby they want to be home
they can't any money so they're going
off to these two separate places to work
now if I told you there's a [ __ ] up
cult man it's what it does is it takes
families and splits them apart that's
the number one thing that you have to do
if you're gonna join this cult you go
one place your wife goes another place
and then they take your baby and put the
baby in a warehouse and they don't
really take care of the baby that well
because there's not enough people there
to do it they're teaching your baby
they're teaching your baby that when you
scream and call out for help no help
comes that's the one of the messages of
the cult you would say that's the most
fucked-up [ __ ] I ever heard my [ __ ]
life that cults got to get shut the [ __ ]
down
fast that cult is called middle-class
life in America
right so as a cult leader I would say
all right what system do you think is
appropriate right is it to subscribe to
the idea that a family is supposed to
spend time together on the weekends and
in the moments before nine o'clock and
after five o'clock is that the idea is
that we're doing here that's that's
that's the plan I don't know man to me
that seems pretty [ __ ] up now if I add
to that that on top of all this [ __ ] the
cult it takes not a tithes of ten
percent but forty to sixty percent of
the income of the family and it doesn't
take it by putting a collection platter
around it just takes it and if you don't
[ __ ] give it you get arrested and
they take all your [ __ ] and you become
homeless potentially and not only that
the cult uses the money and the that
what they do with that [ __ ] money is
they control or remote-controlled
vehicles in other countries and they
drop bombs on people you would say
that's a really [ __ ] up cult man
that's really really bad how is that
allowed to happen that's crazy
we should do something about that you
know so I think the issue is which cult
do you want to be in you know do you
want to like subscribe to the reality
tunnel of well this is just how it is
man this is how it works no it isn't now
works so it's working right now
you know we've eliminated a class in
this country over the last ten years is
a class that's been eliminated
yeah there's no more than mom and the
dad working and mom stays home and
part-time homemaker whatever that's been
eliminated yeah you know we're talking
about yes they would Dodger tickets and
Laker tickets how you know you look at a
Dodger game and laugh when you and I
were growing up it was 12 bucks to go to
a game so yeah brother 24 your dad mom
now to go to like the game it's $500 for
a family so that whole experience has
been taken away yeah as far as life be
the cult I'm not saying life being a
call you could pick your own cult I mean
you live in your own cult if you enjoy
you know those people that you meet that
come to a comedy store and they tell you
everything's amazing I went to this
restaurant it was amazing and they have
oh I went to Duncan's 50th oh my god you
know and Duncan through his own 50th
party those people yeah that's a
complete different cult yeah that's a
cult of wanting to belong there you go
okay I dressed like you yeah I put it
that too on my form like you I have to
go T it's it's it's the skinny jeans I
think that's a cult yeah with no leader
yeah the leader is you and your [ __ ]
head yeah but in the meantime you just
following everybody else's [ __ ] me
that's right me I'm talking about my
friend's parents went to Mexico and met
a guy and the guy sold a new idea of a
community a place where we all work
together remember that sure the late 60s
it was a different time in this country
it was called ain't heavy he's my
brother
yeah so I would say to you Haley what
have you me and Duncan went up to
Pennsylvania bought a farm we grow our
own vegetables which self we'd be on it
for self self-sufficient yeah the cult
that my friend ruined my ex-girlfriend
they were 100% self-sufficient yeah they
grew their own pigs cows they made they
used everything of the em for dessert
they had blood pudding yeah okay if you
go to their house today and sit there
and you look at the mother and the
father and you look at the eight kids
for kids look like the mother in the fog
the other four kids look like yeah I
belong for somebody else I was a cult
leader yeah cuz he was sleeping with the
mom even though in the room right next
door would sure so I'm just gonna let
you come take my wife and go to the room
next door and [ __ ] while I hear you
then he was having kids with these
people's wives yeah and then that wasn't
good enough and he started [ __ ] the
kids all those girls that grew up with
all [ __ ] up in the head that's what I
don't like that all
what you do is you're empty the house
you take the kids you leave the adults
in there you line them up against the
wall and you shoot them all because
they're not gonna do the world any
[ __ ] sure you're not doing it you
just you just shoot people who have no
they sold this off they sold this old
for something I don't know I don't know
that's the way I look at I think it's
you what you're seeing that you can't
see it I it's horrible I mean this is
that Mark Twain quote religion started
when the first conman met the first fool
it's like if you ever find yourself in a
situation or somebody is pitching
something some astounding thing to you
and it doesn't match your instincts but
you decide to like go with them even
though you can feel this isn't right
in that moment you become sadly
complicit in this form of exploitation
you didn't listen to your heart you
listen to the CRA's Matic person and you
got pulled in a little bit and you know
usually the way this [ __ ] works is
there's a name I can't remember the name
once you've invested a certain amount of
money or time and a thing it gets more
and more difficult to leave not because
it's difficult to leave because you're
stuck based in this fallacy of the
amount of dough you've poured into the
[ __ ] thing see you're like I just got
to stay you know this is it this is like
that crazy [ __ ] that you read about
Scientology you know which is like at
the very like that one of the highest
levels they show you a briefcase that
has written on it over on Hubbard's
handwriting which has got you know the
whole like
Xenu stuff basically stuff that just
seems completely antithetical to your
complete understanding of reality and at
that moment you've put in a lot of dough
and you either go oh wow oh [ __ ] this is
kind of embarrassing or you're like well
it must be true it must be true like the
other stuff it must be true and you keep
going right that ignorance is what
that's called
and some people exploit other people's
nerds their blind spots a great magician
like a stage magician what does he do he
knows the [ __ ] you can't see he knows
how to distract you and do all the [ __ ]
and then like while he's doing that he
like makes apparent magic happen and
it's cool but you know it's not real
but it doesn't stop with magic you know
it's it like keeps going so there's
people who understand it human beings
when I said most people don't know
themselves what I meant is humans if
you're raising an alcoholic family
you're taught to ignore the daddy's a
[ __ ] drunk an angry drunk or that
mommy's an angry drunk you're taught to
ignore that you know or if you even
worse you're in a [ __ ] family there's
sexual abuse you know and and you know
if I'm if I talk about this I'm gonna
destroy the family and you will destroy
the family so it's easier to forget it
or it's easier to pretend it didn't
happen or it's easier to try to make
sense of it in your own [ __ ] head and
it's a really sad thing that many of us
have experienced and have done right and
and that is it
the most sad thing which is why I love
that quote in the Bible when Jesus is
talking about you know suffer the little
children to come unto me if anyone
should harm one of these it would be
better that a millstone were tied to
their neck and they were thrown into the
sea and I think in this case what Christ
is saying is not just about children
certainly about children but also about
the other children out there who have
adult bodies but who have no [ __ ]
idea who they are what they are they've
been taught to ignore from the moment
they were born or even worse to make
sense of the fact that their [ __ ]
dad's punching their mom in the [ __ ]
face right or even worse to imagine it's
their fault because you know it's easier
to imagine it's your fault if someone's
hurting you because then you can pretend
you have a little bit of control then to
just realize you're being victimized
right so there are predatory humans in
the world who will prey upon that
quality in others and will and will use
it and will and there's various levels
of it we come welcome to I open up that
door a little yeah just to get some air
in here
thank you welcome to a way yeah look at
that [ __ ] what's that off that
hilarious joke ship Ella has about like
the pent bath you know like the the joke
about how like something about like a
pimple like beat up a prostitute you
know and then give her a bath and she
falls in love with him cuz he's giving
her the bath forgetting about the
[ __ ] abuse that just happened right
like that model of exploitation of human
beings is unfortunately like any other
thing in the world it has evolved and
become refined and what's really sad
about it is there's a [ __ ] ton of people
out there who haven't even thought about
the fact that maybe they're being
tricked by someone you know it's not
[ __ ] you know at least when you're in
a compound and you're looking over and
Jim Jones is mouth [ __ ] your wife
well somebody in the back is stirring a
vat of [ __ ] cyanide and kool-aid at
least in that moment you like out you
like it's at least it's something unique
you're like what the [ __ ] am I done this
is crazy right what the [ __ ] have I done
you know so overt it's so obvious you're
in the jungle you're there's
loudspeakers crackling with this lunatic
who just snorted valium is like he was
shooting my team yes B yeah but so many
people are just in a situation where
they're like surrounded by a group of
friends right and within that group of
friends there's one charismatic front
right and that one charismatic friend
right this this pattern occurs again and
again and again you see it in movies
where it's like the gang and then
there's the leader of the gang or
whatever right and you get this one
[ __ ] dude who like is like smashing
everyone else down out of fear you know
and like many people are in that
situation many people are in
relationships where they're clearly
being abused you know or there's not
you're not supposed to be there people
are in jobs where they're clearly being
[ __ ] exploited right and they slit
that happened they don't do anything you
know so it's like yeah [ __ ] the cult
leaders and [ __ ] anyone who would ever
hurt a kid you know but not just a child
anyone who'd ever hurt anyone who's like
innocent to that degree
those people if there's true
intentionality behind it or I would say
demonic and are in some way shape or
form representative of a type of energy
that I think is unfortunately in many
sectors of society and hopefully is
gradually being diminished by people who
are smart and you've recognized it and
understand okay I know how to do this
we're not gonna do it the old way
necessarily know the old way I mean if
you're something jolly Illuminati three
weeks that what do you see when you see
a little boy my mom really yeah yeah he
looks like my mom Oh what else do you
see besides the nose in the simplicity I
see the beauty of simplicity I see the
hope of the entire not like my son is
the hope of the entire planet but I see
the truth a fundamental goodness in the
world I see that the thing that I've
thought in various states of
consciousness from a psychedelic state
of consciousness to meditation to the
moments I've been falling in love that
oh [ __ ] it's good here
it's okay here this place is good humans
are good this planet is good and this is
a wonderful place to be and it's a it's
important to be here it's not just a
bunch of [ __ ] this is real and
humans have value and they're one of I
see that that's what I see in my child
when I look at it I see that I see hope
I see the reflection of truth in the
world and it isn't the truth that
everyone these days or at least many
cynical people seem addicted to are you
still watching sunshine like it's still
like all new at the house it's only been
three weeks
yes I don't know and I know it's gonna
get complicated I know it doesn't it's
awful but yes walking on sunshine it
feels like I'm in the Garden of Eden for
60 days yeah you see this little child
and then they start looking first you
see that they notice your voice you walk
in a New York
yeah and they look up and they start
kicking their feet cuz they see you and
now you know you're getting through
somebody they've been listening to you
for nine months yeah I call they've been
listening to you for eight months yeah
and now they get to see and now when you
have never forget the time I walked in
the house and I go hey mercy and she
couldn't see but a little feet were
kicking up of the excitement that's a
complete different euphoria you can't
match that with drugs even being on
stage all drugs and all alcohol states
and altered states of consciousness and
all momentary experiences are whether
people know it or not they're going for
that feeling that you have when you're
holding your baby now I'm not saying
reproducing is the only way to get that
but certainly it is the difference
between you know like you smell a rose
perfume and you smell a rose right so
it's like the rose perfumes kind of like
a rose but it sure as [ __ ] isn't a rose
and like having a baby and really like
not just like the experience of like
contacting like the mosaic the genetic
mosaic of your ancestors in the face of
your child but also finally having to
just put yourself on a on up just you
have to put yourself away a what really
they say this is it cuz likes love about
you that's right you're not just dude
love them do nothing to do with you
you're done you're done did you think
you were gonna be [ __ ] dingus Khan no
you're not you're not gonna conquer more
land mass than anybody in the [ __ ]
planet you're not gonna [ __ ] invent
teleportation you're not gonna be Pink
Floyd you're not gonna be Lenny Bruce no
and it doesn't [ __ ] matter cuz this
is better than that this is better and
and and there's something so wonderful
and humbling in that especially for a
judgmental can't like me man because you
know like I so many times I've liked
you know it's it's easy if you could
rationalize your like cowardice or your
selfishness as being some kind of like
revolutionary attitude right and like
for me I would shake my fist at families
in a real cynical way not related to me
too you know yeah did you what age did
you can that you think children would be
a possibility in your life never never I
went through a period where I thought
maybe I'll have a kid I worked at a
summer camp man I [ __ ] love kids then
I just gave up I'm like I'm not gonna do
that I got real real like I went through
a pretty dark period in my life man I
got real cynical I got real cynical real
numb and real like pseudo I don't know I
was being lazy man and I was trying to
like make my laziness seem smart or
something or I was trying to like just a
like you know imitative you look around
you see the most [ __ ] powerful person
around if they're cynically all right
maybe I'll be cynical
you don't even question why I
necessarily you just start or even worse
you're aggressive so you want to get a
charge out of people so you read some
[ __ ] Nietzsche or some [ __ ] you know
and then you get around people you don't
care about Nietzsche the will the power
the sheeple all that nonsense you know
you care about you care about telling
some dumb ghost story like throwing
firecrackers at people so you get this
temporary rise out of people like wow
yeah tell you about [ __ ] Nietzsche
man anything that doesn't destroy us
only makes us stronger you haven't even
thought about what that means you just
say it well there's people just
regurgitating [ __ ] that'll around bad I
know what the [ __ ] yeah
how did you I mean nothing soultion
anyway and sold me go ahead you're a
ladies man ever since I've known you had
you decide on this one to be the mom of
your child holy [ __ ] man thanks for that
that's a great question uh and it's an
embarrassing answer which is that
because I'd hurt this I'd heard it so
many times and I always rolled my eyes
at it secretly you know who said it to
me Freddy Soto he said it to me about
Corey he's like you know I met her and I
just knew I'm going to marry her
and I remember him telling me that I
mean like what the [ __ ] he talking about
that's not real and I've heard that you
know in various other places in a
million like sort of nauseating romantic
movies and songs but holy [ __ ] and
that's real it was the craziest thing
and like it was it was like fusion or
something like I met her we started
hanging out and this dawning realization
was happening in both of us it was like
we're gonna get married we're gonna
we're gonna have a baby
and I can't explain it it's like all
right it's like the way the Sun comes up
it wasn't like some flash or anything it
was just more like whoa this is this is
it this is like the thing this is the
thing it's happening to us
we're like you guys marry what you man
yeah we're married you might be tough
you guys got married officially before
yeah baby
it happened real quick man and I mean
like it sounds irresponsible and I get
it on paper it sounds it sounds insane
you know I asked her parents permission
like cuz I'm from the south and that's
what we do yeah hold my I quote Terry's
father when when I was talking to her
dad I could he you know I like I could I
get it I think he thought oh is this
like some kind of thing where you like
knocked up my daughter or something and
now you're gonna get married or said I
don't I don't what I'm not sure that I
could have been purged it by like I get
it you know but no what happened was we
just wanted to have a baby officer I
like like two months before I've been
telling my brother I'm not gonna
reproduce in this life I'm just not
gonna have a baby I'm not gonna do that
and then suddenly it was the most
amazing encounter with truth and and
it's all any articulation of it just
sounds like a [ __ ] cliche man it just
sounds like a cliche so it's like God
what is it what is it when God laughs
when man makes plans you know that thing
you know or like true yeah I didn't
think this is ever gonna happen yeah
after the first ordeal I didn't think it
was in my realm just a negative thinking
about it would keep it away and yeah
it's nothing there even the whole thing
about marriage and whatever I'm
I married her and and you know two or
three days later she was knocked out it
was like that it was and I knew it I
knew it when we first went on our first
date with the jack-in-the-box on the way
home that's how broke we were went to
Jack of the baja and I knew it in the
drive-in lion that I was going to spend
some time with this woman that I didn't
know she was the woman of my dreams or
whatever just but just how she was
talking to me I had never really I had
always dominated a conversation with
women she wouldn't allow that to happen
I was like and she's she's amazing ya
know we looked and we hit the jackpot
yeah man and and I to me it's like the
realization that you it's painful to
think that you're the country that
you're in control
it's [ __ ] painful man and like people
want to be in control but it's a painful
thing to imagine you're in control and
and there are certain things you need to
be in control of obviously you know you
need to be in control of like how much
you're drinking how much you're sleeping
these things that's discipline right but
there's certain things you have no
control over at all there's bit there's
like invisible gears in the universe and
they're turning very slowly and you're
part of that and sometimes even though
your life seems as bleak as it could
[ __ ] be man and you're numb and
you're [ __ ] sad things are still
moving yeah just cuz you're numb the
world doesn't stop that's right
it's so [ __ ] weird it's so weird this
light for this journey so far from me
has been I learned something every
[ __ ] day and then I look at people
and learn from them you know when you
were in New York you were happy you had
the model girlfriend next thing are you
back in LA
you marry some chick three weeks later
you're gonna have a baby yeah just and
on top of that you endured the two
losses which I am very sorry for thank
you and very fond of your father he
loved you so I've been thinking lately a
lot about you know cuz I lost my mother
you know
thirty [ __ ] years ago it doesn't
matter but for somebody like you to look
at that child now and go I wish dad
could how about an extra two more
nightly wished mom canal bond extra 18
months and then you know but they're
looking down on us do you believe
they're looking down on that job yeah
man I'd like to tell me what yeah one of
the things that happen as he was dying
you know he's asleep and he had his
phone and he had a picture of the UH at
the ultrasound you know he was just
looking at the ultrasound and he fell
asleep but he are you loved you Joe and
like Hugh made such a big impression on
it he completed you to me meeting him
made me understand who you were and we
became brothers at that moment yeah yeah
I came brothers at that moment so it was
I'm very proud of you thank you happy
for what's going on and I know you got
to get back the mother was gonna [ __ ]
wait I want to answer your question what
happened to uh
sorry got teary-eyed man no I want you
to get to this podcast about I got teary
I think I had a dream and I will
probably get teary out again when I say
this I'm sorry I had this dream after he
died and you know when you dream
sometimes about somebody's past and it's
more than a dream it's just not a dream
it feels like you're there with them yes
so my dad he he lived in apartments most
of his life you know and um my dad loved
life that's why I loved you and that's
why you two connected because you both
have this just you love life you love
life and it's it's just it's such a
wonderful thing because whether you're
doing great or whether things are down
you love life we're alive
yeah well yeah what do you mean you lost
a foot yeah you're alive you can still
eat [ __ ] yeah what are you looking at
this Oh what you can't walk through the
show you got a roller skate yeah
we put there's always a [ __ ] bright
side I'm sorry to interrupt that's it
though man and that relationship with
life is very romantic and it's wonderful
and it helps everybody around you and
after he passed you know I was talking
to people who like he was always giving
gifts to people I went down to the like
to like talk to the people at his
apartment you know about like getting
the place clean and everything and they
were talking about how I could
Thanksgiving he bring him a turkey and
stop he was always giving giving giving
you giving he was very but secretly he
never talked about this [ __ ] man
and he like he was in Vietnam and yet
yeah you know he like had a lot of like
medals that we found after he passed
never [ __ ] talked about it man never
talking about dude like I had someone go
through it I don't want to say it here
because I just I'm afraid like yeah I
don't want to like insult anyone in the
military by accidentally saying my dad
had achieved this or that but they're
really intense ones man and they were
just in a drawer you know they're just
in a drawer he was a via though he was
in Vietnam he went and he went for two
tours and he went you know he
volunteered to go out for the second one
but the UH the dream I had was damaged
mmm the dream I had was I was talking to
him right and uh he would show me his
new apartment and he was he liked it
because it was right on the ocean it had
an ocean view and he was like super
proud of it he would've loved that in
real life and he loved it in the dream
and uh and he said yeah but I've got
these neighbors upstairs and he's like
they seem like they're your friends see
what their aliens are so I know they are
and then like I looked up in the dream
and there's like these two Buddhist
monks in robes that are like standing
behind it and uh it was cool man it was
like a feeling of like okay just maybe
maybe just maybe cuz like when I was
when he was passing I was teaching him
some
chose you know I was teaching him um on
the Padma hammam on the whole the whole
did you in the heart of Lotus and I he
was chanting it a little bit and as he
was passing he got real you know got
real that's what happens people are
dying to get real and we had some great
conversations about death and what was
going to happen what I heard and what it
is and so I don't know it's a really
beautiful dream and it made me gave me
some hope that whatever happens after
that maybe some people came and like
guided him through that process you know
who were maybe a part of the Buddhist
Sangha the Dharma as they call it and I
don't know it was just a dream you know
but I do know this he died in a really
sweet way he died in a really sweet way
man and that says a lot about a person I
pretend not yeah and he loved you one
door closed with another warrant open
that's right and now you get to relive
your dad through him he's got his
you-know-whats cool he looks like my mom
and he's got my dad's dimple and he's
got my dad's hair so it's the most
beautiful thing I mean I don't mean it's
just so wonderful
I listen I I know when I talk to you on
the phone you're a new person
yes yeah for everything that you've gone
through this child is cleansed it all
the way there's still some pain there
residue yeah it's not what it was I had
the same thing so it's like I said I'm
just happy you made time what are you
gonna get back at the common [ __ ] get
mobile back on the stage I feel it I'm
coming back soon you know I just said I
had to get out the store yes or you have
to do this yeah nobody says you gotta go
on the road you start at the store twice
a week see your friends talk to other
people you know well everybody that got
a kid now bill burr got a kid you got a
kid I think ones other kids roaming got
kids time to go got kids but I she's got
kids so it's like you're in not only a
comedian community that you're in that
parent how are you I'm gonna be back
Joey thank you so much for you
so I'm happy you made it out let's keep
in touch I'll come down about four or
five weeks and love it odd cast
that'd be great man and thanks so much
man you're awesome dude you're so funny
man I you know I don't watch a lot of
podcasts but you're you the energy you
guys have with each other is so [ __ ]
funny man you you [ __ ] killed
Thursday night
yeah how the heck we came up to him
uh-huh I thought I was in a dive I
thought I just turned away like this is
my son [ __ ] turned away cuz I was
like he's gonna fall apart
and I heard this huge loud explosion of
applause that was so proud of because
the night before we had taken some THC
and he I left him to quarter to nine and
I asked him how long he goes when I did
the audio and whatever and he passed out
and he woke up at 6:30 in the mornings
you know like when you wake up all over
yeah he had that feeling sorry let me
test his comic skills under those
conditions cuz that's gonna happen to
him on the road well yeah he's gonna
meet a broad he's gonna go back they're
gonna get him drunk he's gonna wake up
at 5:00 and he's gotta go do the gig
feeling shitty yeah and he [ __ ]
destroyed before I grabbed his 500 it's
so cool man you've been taken under the
wing of the true samurai but last night
he was a Riverside dinosaur that's a now
he's mad at me but hey it's gonna die
last night what's so funny I died I go
this is the life [ __ ] this let
me just say this you guys are awesome
you this podcast is very special I just
hope you all know that I'm sure you hear
from your fans all the time but anytime
I like it pops up on YouTube and I watch
you guys it's not like you even have to
say anything man just when you're
bobbing around dancing it's the energy
you're putting out there it feels real
good to watch people like you doing a
show like this man so thank you so much
feelin me now no nothing
that's it I'm happy you got a chance to
come on I want to thank Duncan Trussell
I want to thank the flying [ __ ]
Jew and I want to thank you guys that
came out to Brea this weekend and for
all your support
don't forget Valentine's Day San Jose
improv and then the week after that the
22nd I'm at Treasure Island and the 23rd
I'm at Fox Theatre in Tucson
the kidnap we're showing up the
kidnappee hopefully everything will be
smooth all right I want to thank my man
Duncan Trussell for coming in and making
me cry he cried I want to thank the
[ __ ] for being a bad
[ __ ] but most importantly I want
to thank you guys for always having my
back okay you got the dates Valentine's
Day in San Jose and the rest of the
weekend and then the 22nd and tret at
Treasure Island or Las Vegas with my
girl Kate Quigley and then on the 23rd
the next night I'm at the Fox Theater in
Tucson note I will not be going to Tempe
or Phoenix this year so if you don't see
me in Tucson you're [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
luck show Tucson is the way to go
before I go I just want to talk about
our sponsors for a minute all right you
want to turn a cool idea into a new
website right you want to showcase your
work you want a blog or publish content
you want to sell products and services
of all kinds and you want to promote
your physical or your online business
you know how you do it
Squarespace okay Squarespace space uses
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers with a powerful
ecommerce functionality it lets you sell
anything online plus the ability to
customize look and feel settings
products and more with just a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box a new way to buy domains
and choose over from 200 extensions
analytics that will help you grow in
real time nothing to patch or upgrade
ever and 24/7 award-winning customer
support
that's what Squarespace offers you
should do me a favor head over to
squarespace.com right now for a free
trial right now squarespace.com is
giving the church family a free trial
when you're ready to launch you use the
offer code Church to save 10% off your
purchase of a website or a domain who
takes care you like me Squarespace and
me so go to squarespace.com right now
and enter code Church right now you want
to get your life going you want to
publish that book you want to show
people your pictures this is how it
starts with Squarespace go to
Squarespace calm right now for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code Church and save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
enter code church I want to thank
Squarespace I want to thank God and I
want to thank all of you guys for being
loyal soldiers and forgive me the love
that uh I guess I needed as a kid
you guys are my psychotherapy I love you
guys see you Wednesday morning ready a
rock tip-top [ __ ] Magoo Lee
kick this [ __ ] meal I love you guys
have a great week this is the way to
start it